last week's poison gas attack killed
more than 80 civilians many of them
children they included the loved ones of
Abdul Hameed al yousuf a father whose
loss is impossible to measure Polly
Williams has his story we want to warn
you that the aftermath of the attack was
captured in disturbing video this is the
face of Syria's Civil War a young man
who's just lost 29 of his family members
including his wife and twin babies they
were both really smart he told us I
wanted my daughter aya to be a doctor
and Ummat was going to be my sidekick he
buried them on Wednesday the day after a
suspected chemical attack on his town
hansha hoon you chose to carry your
babies in your arms to be buried and I
wonder why did you why did you do that
because that's how I carried them when
they were alive he said I loved them so
much and I know they loved Abdul Hameed
told us he buried them next to each
other and told them not to be scared
even in the cruelty and chaos of syria's
six year long civil war the attack on
hon shite moon stands out for its
brutality witnesses say a bomb fell from
the sky that didn't explode but left
them struggling to breathe some foaming
at the mouth and suffocating to death
it happened on Abdul Hameed second
anniversary with his wife Jalal do you
think that the American missile strikes
will make any difference I thought it
was a good start
Abdul Hameed told us but the regime
airstrikes haven't stopped for CBS this
morning Holly Williams near the
turkey-syria border staggering
staggering grief that father and what
he's been through and lost so many
members of his family he nine in that
attack